i mean i was shocked at how nice
how beautiful new york was and how you
know i i remember it you know i loved
you i would never live there again
but i just i i loved it man i love
walking by and a guy like you you're a
young guy you should be there if you're
a young person move to new york
date meet young people get stabbed
if you have to take a bullet
gives you a little character gives you a
little story
but i'm telling you right now i i think
the media has hyped this up
and this whole james altucher who i like
he's a sweet guy he's like a bootleg
malcolm gladwell
and i and i and i mean and i don't mean
that to offend him but he looks like
malcolm gladwell
he's a big fan of this podcast i'll
teacher he's uh he's a really nice guy
he's a fan of comedy he's a comedian to
some degree
um and i and he owns he's a part owner
of stand-up new york
uh which is one of the worst comedy
clubs in the country
uh and a place where every time i have
to perform i've considered blowing my
brains out
on the way there instead i do it and and
it's fine i'm listen i'm not i'm
a kid i kid them and i don't i don't
care
about working there anymore but i'm i'm
backing governors love governors thank
you
we we we healed our wounds and we're and
we're now back together
we're back together and we'll do that
with stan in new york too if they get
because i can sell a little tickets now
so
they'll be okay it's it's a massage
front it is what it is thank you
anyway i did a new year's eve show there
once and the owner brought in like three
tables of people and they were eating
food out of like big tins and
it's it's a massage front for weapons
for the uh for the uh
uh idf anyway moving on doesn't matter
who cares
anyway it doesn't matter al tucha is a
part owner of this business why because
it's a scam
and he's like a bitcoin guy and he's
he's involved in all kinds of different
things which i appreciate
his new thing's going to be like
doomsday prepper he's going to be
selling
uh you know doomsday prep kits hey you
can run your business from your doomsday
hole you know
10 tips for the modern business prep but
dan's nervous because he wants to work
these clubs but i don't care
but james is a sweetheart of a guy right
and he bought into this massage scam
and he he does like you know every now
and then he'll do a bitcoin seminar in
between two of the comics which is very
helpful for his show
you know i'll get up do jokes and then
he'll come up and talk about ethereum
so
we're having fun i'm sure he enjoys this
my my job is my job folks
so james bought into uh a stand-up new
york massage scam
and he they just made the bartender the
booker once they just
they just one of the mexican guys that
was wiping off the table they go now you
booked the club he goes
huh okay who what what
okay here is line up godfrey
godfrey
tim dylan uh i don't i don't know who's
who is this
uh lori kilmartin ah okay
you're the booker now you washed the
dishes now you booked the club now you
curate the entertainment for the
audience
they just give everett the homeless guy
across the street was the booker you
used to have to go and audition for him
he was blind she would have to you know
feel your face with his fingers anyway
so altura buys into this club
which is and by the way the new york
times jason zinniman the
the writer for the new york times comedy
section he still has a job
amazing maybe the recession isn't that
bad
jason who i like who's been on the
program open invitation again unlike
madrid vulture who will not come on i
don't know why i'm respectful to
everyone
come on but she doesn't want to leave
her apartment she's cocooned in there
with many cats don't know
but come on let's talk i i don't even
hate her i i don't
like what she does but i don't hate her
i like that archetype of woman who's
like
kind of strange and you know but
committed to her work like i like i like
a
like a monastery type of like just
typing and
i like i'm like that i don't have
friends and things i like what she's
doing
come and join me and we'll sit at
opposite ends of the table and we'll
talk about how our careers or our lives
and our lives are horrible
yes or yes meg so jason wrote this whole
thing about how
it's so great to do stand-up comedy in
central park and
you know on on the shores of the east
river and in a cab it's so nice and
the state of new york's producing a lot
of these outdoor comedy shows now
because people
when people just get out of a four-month
coven isolation and they're laying in
the park what they really want is
somebody yelling about their [ __ ]
that's what they want they're just
trying to set speed in the park with
their family and they need
some insecure psychopath babbling in the
park
so james altucher part owner of stand-up
new york who's uh on the avant-garde
here and on the vanguard of all these
new
comedy experiences curating all these
comedy experiences
in the park uh james o'tooter writes an
article called new york is dead
and it's never coming back and people
are very very angry about that because
our teacher
very smart guy knows what he's doing a
little bit of a troll
knows what he's gonna do when he says
new york's dead what's gonna happen
who's gonna puff up their chest some
gazillionaire
like jerry seinfeld
so jerry seinfeld who is
a legend a king whatever you want he's
great it is what it is
probably wouldn't love me but wouldn't
like my comedy maybe he would don't know
so jerry writes an article saying hey
new york's gonna be okay
it is what it is you know and that's the
whole article i mean there's more parts
of it but
you know it's not that funny but it's
fun and it's jerry going
uh hey he goes yeah i've never been to
new york i have a house in long island
which is i mean he's an estate in
hampton's household now but whatever
he's allowed to say that right it is
what it is
so everybody you know so jerry goes new
york's gonna be fine everybody's gonna
be fine
shut the [ __ ] up and i saw him recently
out here
in the hamptons jerry and he was just
pulling
he was pulling the the masks off off off
waiters and waitresses and then deep
mouth kissing them
and gender unimportant and then kiss him
and then he would say new york is back
[ __ ] and he'd say open your mouth and
then he'd spit in their mouth and i was
like
that's the type of guy that i think is
important to have i think he needs
someone
who's kind of tough like that and who's
really has a passion for the city i like
that i saw him hit a hit of maid with
his car
and he just said new york's back [ __ ]
and kept driving
and that i like that but so jerry got in
the new york times and just basically
did
a takedown of valtutron he called him a
putts
i love jerry seinfeld insults they're
like from 1935.
this guy's the putts he's a louse
this this look at this carnival barker
so jerry's insulting this guy with
depression error
slang in the new york times i think al
tucha responds in the post
and it's just been a knock down drag out
of rich guys
who don't live in the city currently
arguing about if the city's going to be
back
and guys the city is already back it's
actually
doing fine i mean things aren't open
things will open but the city is doing
fine yes there is crime there are
problems
there are issues with the police from
what i gather
but the city itself is actually okay
so we have this tug of war between a
james
altucher at standup new york and of
course i kid stand up new york i
i love you guys i'd love to perform on a
barge in the east river
if you have my email and you have james
altucher going at uh a legendary
king of the hamptons jerry seinfeld
and they just it's a knock down throw
down fight the two men are much more
successful than your humble
podcaster here so all i say is hey it's
fun
i want to write a third article called
new york's not dead
but let's kill it and it would be
outlining the reasons to kill new york
and
how to do it that would be the humorous
take which
jerry and altucher decided not to be
humorous in their articles
following the ethos of comedy right now
to be very serious
all the time and make tiny little jokes
kind of
that's what we do and that's who we give
specials to and those people become
uh millionaires but i would like to
write an article called new york is not
dead but
[ __ ] me if i ain't gonna try let's kill
it
here's how to kill it and i would then
just list you know
an eight point plan or a ten point plan
about how to destroy
uh new york city i think that would be
that would be fun i don't know if that's
gonna happen or not
probably not but you know we will see
but that that's been a very interesting
war that has been brewing uh
in the comedy world that is uh what the
comedy world has been kind of talking
about and what
it's bled out into uh anybody that's on
twitter or really anybody that's
in new york's probably come across one
of those articles
saying that new york is dead forever and
here's why and i'll teach you made some
good points
he said the internet speed allows you to
conduct business wherever you want
so why the hell are you doing in new
york and jerry seinfeld's whole point
was that uh which i thought was also a
good point he's like
where else can you kill a maid and then
have it covered up in under six
hours and have her body buried in the
park so
both of them have a good point and i
think both of them should
be heard and by the way guys
you are so welcome to come on the show
you're so welcome to come on the show
jerry and al tucher
and me just a couple of guys just a
couple of guys that want
the best for the [ __ ] greatest city
in the world okay
and i'll rent a nice airbnb i won't be
hearing this montauk surf
[ __ ] i'm gonna burn this place down
you gotta be on ayahuasca i think this
is a [ __ ]
nice place i paid for luxury experience
and i didn't get it
and when i'm promised luxury and i don't
get it i squeal like a pig
i squeal like a pig like a privileged
vindictive petty little pig that's a
petty little pig
if you heard me squealing from a mile
away you'd go that
pig didn't get luxury that pig was
expecting luxury and didn't get it
what a petty little pig and i'd go
i'd make a sound like that and i
wouldn't stop
and they'd toss and turn in their beds
and they wouldn't be able to sleep
and the kids would run into the rooms
and the kids would go why can't i sleep
there's this blood
curdling scream and the parents would
say
son i'll tell you i'll tell you a lesson
you're going to learn a lesson right now
if you promise a pig
luxury you better deliver because if you
don't
that pig will scream until that pig can
scream no more
do you understand that daddy why is
luxury so important to the pig
well the pig has a little else son the
pig likes the luxury the pig likes the
creature comforts
that is why pigs exist to put themselves
in situations where they can get
creature comforts
and if they are promised these things
and they don't get them they believe
that the entire world should be burned
to the ground son
even our family yes yes
a pig who's promised luxury and not
delivered it would watch you your sister
me and your mother
burned to death without a tear in his
eye no emotion
because a pig deserves luxury i don't
deserve
[ __ ] wooden benches with [ __ ] a
blanket over them
how dare you how dare you and i don't
usually leave
bad reviews on the airbnb but i'm going
to write
on airbnb that this woman uh had clan
memorabilia
in her house i'm going to say that i was
very uncomfortable
by a room in her house that was
dedicated to a history of the klu klux
klan
which her grandfather was in and she was
very proud of she said i'm very proud of
my heritage by the way she texted me
that she's like the last people at a
party of six people it was a big deal
there was trash all over the yard people
have food out
please don't be that guy and i'm like
[ __ ]
i'm not gonna be that guy i do the same
thing in every airbnb this is my two
week end of summer vacation then we'll
be back in the studio
next week every airbnb i sit in the
backyard and i scream for several hours
into a microphone that is my job the guy
yesterday's like i called the cops i'm
like
it's my job sir my job isn't like your
job to just go around and shoot people
whenever you feel like it
my job is to communicate with the body
politic
with the public i have to speak to the
public it's not my fault